soon robe sûr sensation
bonjour et bienvenue dans une europe sur
radio sensations et tv 78 une émission
spéciale réalisée depuis le 75e festival
de cannes alors vous avez sûrement en
tête les nombreuses stars qui se
succèdent sur le tapis rouge qui est
juste derrière moi mais ici se trouvent
également des milliers de professionnels
du secteur dans le cadre du marché du
film corentin alonso est allé à la
rencontre de certains d'entre eux ils
sont venus ici promouvoir des films ou
même des lieux de tournage du monde
entier le marché du film c'est le salon
des professionnels du cinéma douze mille
participants 7000 société 350 exposants
120 pays la belgique est naturellement
représentés christian de shooter de
flandre images
enfin
je suis ici pour la promotion des films
qui sont faits en flandre et à bruxelles
en belgique et bien sûr c'est une année
extraordinaire parce que nous avons
trois films en sélection officielle dont
deux sont en compétition il ya donc un
film qui s'appelle clause l'autre
s'appelle i hate mountains et le
troisième qui est en sélection
officielle s'appelle rebelles nous
sommes très heureux de cette grande
sélection c'est une grande année pour
nous et bien sûr à part ça nous sommes
aussi ici pour parler des films qui sont
en préparation et qui seront prêts dans
les 12 prochains mois parce que bien sûr
il ya d'autres équipes qui sont
actuellement en production et en post
production et nous rencontrons ici des
festivals des commerciaux et des
distributeurs pour parler de ses films
et nous espérons qu'ils trouveront
également le chemin des grands festivals
dans les prochains mois
ici aussi pour promouvoir leur film et
faire du business les italiens de true
colors
francesca tiberi dispose d'un vaste
catalogue
pour sa talents et donc combien tous les
années qui a le marché du film pour
présenter nos films à qui on a dans
notre line up par exemple
nous chez troc alors cette année on
vient ici à présenter le film nostalgie
avec quel fiasco fabi nom est dirigée
par mario martone en compétition
officielle et donc on entrerait c'est de
l'exporter le cinéma italien dans le
monde entier et le marché du film c'est
le rendez vous annuel
[Musique]
préféré parfaitement pour venir ici à
présent donner au film un des six buts
en entier nom célèbre
film présenté en sélection officielle
nostalgia 27 ans après l'amour meurtri
son réalisateur mario martone se
retrouve kad c'est l'histoire de felhi
cherasco un mec qui revient à naples
après avoir vécu aux quarante ans
dallas
maroc et du egypte tout ça et ils
rentrent 1 1 pl pour voir sa mère
et il va chercher un peu son passé un
implant à cannes la concurrence est rude
aussi entre les pays et les régions pour
accueillir des tournages rendez-vous
dans les salons d'un palace pour une
opération séduction nicolas tarantino de
la sicilia film commission partage sa
vision cinématographique la sicile le
pays aux mille scénarios
ce que je voulais dire c'est que je
n'arrive vraiment pas à imaginer qu'un
film ne puisse pas se situer en sicile
sauf peut-être pour le décor glacial du
pôle nord et du pôle sud après un
scénario aussi s'il peut être parfait
pour illustrer de n'importe quelle
situation parce que nous avons des
volcans la maire des îles des villes
d'art des parcs archéologiques des parcs
naturels il ya clairement plusieurs
choix serre située des histoires de
n'importe quel type
la sicile sera le décor de sicile hot
holidays un film dont le tournage
débutera en septembre prochain
le festival de cannes c'est une
compétition et en sélection officielle
le film triangle of sadness du
réalisateur suédois ruben ostlund un
film qui a bénéficié du soutien de
l'union européenne c'est d'ailleurs
notre film coup de coeur il se déroule
dans le monde des influenceurs et des
super-riches courant alonso s'est
glissée la conférence de presse du film
une fois rencontrant les producteurs
génique c est un film sur la mode qui
ceux qui continuent sur un paquebot et
qui se termine sur une île
et montreux un couple qui suit tout ce
voyage et gens qui considèrent que leur
apparence physique est une sorte de
mener puis on va voir un capitaine maxis
sur le pas de mots qui est jouée par
woody harrelson
et qui va organiser le dîner du
capitaine le jour où il ya eu c'est
qu'en fait c'est bien que tous les
passagers tombe malade et il
s'enivre avec un milliardaire russe et
puis ils lisent le cône le manifeste
communiste à travers son micro de façon
à ce que tous les passagers du paquebot
l'entendent
et puis tout le monde veut ni à cause de
la tempête et pis ça va être la fin de
la civilisation occidentale
puisque je viens du monde de la mode je
sais de quoi je parle effectivement la
beauté joue un rôle qu'on en ait
conscience ou pas et on se rend compte
dans ce film c'est cela qui rend le film
aussi intéressant dans la vie de tous
les jours nous avons de l'amener avec
nous que ce soit notre richesse notre
beauté où notre pouvoir et on place est
menée dans ce film dans une situation où
cette monnaie là n'a plus aucune valeur
et donc fait ce qu'est ce qu'on devient
deux communes
oui j'ai utilisé mon expérience de la
transition yougoslavie ce passage
l'économie socialiste au capitalisme
donc pour
incarner ce personnage je savais de quoi
je parlais
[Musique]
ce qui est intéressant dans ce film
c'est qu'on y trouve énormément de
messages différents
chaque message est perçu différemment
par chacun d'entre nous l'idée de
l'égalité me plaît
il faut bien réfléchir aux notions de
l'hiérarchie
lorsqu'on est dans le haut de la
hiérarchie il faut traiter ceux qui sont
en bas de la hiérarchie d'une façon
plaisante je crois que c'est un message
puissant qu'il n'a eu que lorsque l'on
dit dans ce film notamment qu'il ne faut
pas traiter les subalternes comme de la
merde donc c'est un message qui est très
intéressant et il faut que l'on
réfléchisse davantage aux notions
d'égalité que nous le faisons
sur europe
tusa présent avec margot la cause
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes en
charge du volet médias au sein du bureau
europe créative france alors le
programme créative europe médias
supporte le secteur audiovisuel européen
depuis 1991 depuis son lancement 47 film
financé par le programme ont obtenu des
récompenses au festival de cannes dont
par exemple la dernière palme d'or ici à
cannes qui est attribué à la
réalisatrice julia ducournau pour le
film titane l'année dernière cette année
ses quinze films financés qui sont
sélectionnés dans les différentes
sélections du festival de cannes déjà
premièrement pourquoi est ce que c'est
important pour l'europe d'être présente
ici à cannes
on est très heureux de pouvoir revenir à
cannes avec une présence européenne très
forte d'un déjà dans les films qui sont
sélectionnés dans toutes les
compétitions
à cannes et surtout avec une présence de
l'industrie européenne une présence
aussi politique avec la venue du
commissaire breton à cannes et qui
s'incarne aussi par la volonté de médias
de faire partie en fait de l'audiovisuel
européen donc on a un stand ici qui est
très actif qui permet d'accueillir
énormément d'européens professionnels de
la distribution de la production ou même
de plus ceux liés
l'industrie et qui sont là vraiment pour
échanger on essaye au maximum de
travailler à cette question de la
coopération européenne pour notre
audiovisuel européen
vous ici vous accueillez sur votre stand
vous vous le disiez des producteurs par
exemple d'où viennent ces gens vous
parler d'europe à ce que l'europe et est
représenté
de la même façon partout dans le monde
du cinéma ou est ce que l'on voit plus
de français parce que nous sommes en
france que qu'est ce qu'elle est
publique on a un pavillon qui est
vraiment européen et il faut savoir que
sur le programme europe créative médias
nine géographique un peu plus large que
les 27 de l'union européenne c'est un
programme qui accueille
35 pays y compris donc tous les pays en
voie d'adhésion
et de l'espace économique européen donc
on a vraiment une présence d'une
présence à ces diverses niveau des
professionnels alors oui bien sûr les
professionnels français sont assez se
représenter mais sa ligne à l'image
aussi du dynamisme du secteur du secteur
français dans l'industrie audiovisuelle
mais je tiens à souligner qu'on a quand
même beaucoup de professionnels
européens du nord du sud jusqu à l'est
alors qu'anne c'est une vitrine pour le
cinéma du monde entier c'est d'ailleurs
le premier festival de cinéma de l'année
un film primé à cannes de grandes
chances de se voir sélectionné par
exemple en allemagne à berlin à venise
au par exemple à toronto
est ce que c'est important pour les
films qui sont financés par média de se
voir représenter également en dehors de
l'europe oui puisque l'un des objets
premier de ce programme c'est de
permettre aussi de favoriser la
circulation des films européens
au sein des frontières de l'europe mais
aussi à l'international et
mais cannes est vraiment la place pour
pouvoir travailler justement à hostens
un réel marché donc
l'acquisition et vente des projets on
espère après retrouver du coup certains
films qui auraient fait l'objet d'une
acquisition ici se retrouvait après
peut-être ultérieurement soutenu par
média puisque médias aussi accompagne
beaucoup à la circulation des films à
travers des soutiens spécifiques pour
les vendeurs et les distributeurs qui
lie soutien du budget le budget du
programme il a augmenté par rapport à
l'année dernière par rapport à 2021 a
augmenté de 31% il se porte à 3 185 6
millions d'euros cette année quels sont
les objectifs de la commission
européenne à travers leur les cultures
europe justement en augmentant ce budget
l'idée en fait de ce nouveau programme
c'est c'est une augmentation qui a été
fait pour l'ensemble de la période
budgétaire donc de 2021 et 2027 donc un
programme en forte augmentation
pour accompagner l'ambition de ce
nouveau programme europe créative à
plusieurs écueils le premier c'est
d'accompagner le secteur dans une
relance résiliente plus verte et aussi
de travailler à transition au numérique
du secteur donc c'est pour ça aussi
qu'il ya beaucoup de financements qui
sont axées en 2022 pour être le plus
actif possible dès le début en fait du
programme sur 2021 et 2027 pour pouvoir
participer à un maximum d'initiatives
paneuropéenne dans le secteur de
l'industrie audiovisuelle puis d'autre
part aussi il y avait une volonté
d'intégrer plus largement sur l'ensemble
du programme europe créatif qui lui
couvrent l'ensemble du secteur des
industries culturelles et créatives
au delà et médias qui couvrent
particulièrement l'audiovisuel européens
d'augmenter aussi sa contribution à
travers un volet spécifique s'appelle le
volet trans sectoriel qui a vocation à
rassembler ensemble des initiatives qui
seraient qui mêlerait audiovisuels et
autres industries créatives et aussi
qu'ils souhaiteraient soutenir des
initiatives qui permettent d'engager
d'accompagner le pluralisme
en europe et des soutiens aux médias et
au journalisme aussi également merci
beaucoup margot la cause avoir été avec
nous je rappelle que vous êtes en charge
du volet médias au sein du bureau europe
créatif france merci à vous
zone europe
en europe la fréquentation des cinémas a
chuté de 60% avant la pandémie le nombre
de billets vendus frôlé le milliard et
l'an dernier il est tombé sous la barre
des 400 milles alors comment attirer
plus de spectateurs pour les films
européens c'était le thème d'une
conférence organisée par l'observatoire
européen de l'audiovisuel
on écoute tout de suite mathilde fiq et
c'est la secrétaire générale de la cepi
coordination européenne des producteurs
indépendants ce que moi j'ai vraiment
retenu c'est qu'en fait c'est un
équilibre qui est assez délicat à
trouver surtout dans un marché qui
change énormément avec des nouveaux
player les streamers des plateformes et
c'est parce que d'un côté en tant que
producteur représentants de
représentants des producteurs européens
on a besoin de pouvoir financer des
films grâce aux licences dans chaque
dans chaque pays et on a besoin de
pouvoir investir dans des nouveaux
projets donc on a un business model
derrière le film qui est extrêmement
important puisque c'est ça qui nous
permet d'avoir ces nouveaux films ces
nouveaux films indépendants cette
nouvelle création qui fait que les gens
aiment aller au cinéma le deuxième point
qu'on a entendu qui était extrêmement
important c'est l'importance d'investir
pour connecter l'audience avec un fim
comprendre ce que les gens veulent voir
mais également investir de manière à
faire de la promotion à faire connaître
le film et à encourager les gens à aller
au cinéma et ça c'est également un
effort qui est extrêmement important
mais qui récolte qui réclame aussi un
investissement qui doit être coupé donc
on en revient au problème de balancer en
fait l'accès au contenu est arrivé à
financer un modèle qui est extrêmement
important et qui nous permet d'avoir une
diversité de films en europe on va
parler d'éducation à l'image à présent
des jeunes français des jeunes allemands
sont venus participer en collaboration
avec l'oph âge à la semaine de la
critique une sélection parallèle du
festival de cannes pour se former à la
critique du cinéma mathis godefroy les a
suivis dans le cadre de la semaine de la
critique ici au festival de cannes et
nous allons suivre aujourd'hui des
jeunes lycéens français et allemands qui
vont assister à la projection d'un film
la rolls yade andrés ramires pulido
l'objectif est de par la suite écrire
une critique suivez moi on va à la
rencontre parmi eux certains
s'intéressent plus que d'autres à la
profession c'est notamment le cas de
daniela l'objectif c'est mnc
d'approfondir ma culture
cinématographique regarder des films et
apprendre à les analyser en temps être
me plonger dans le métier de
d'analystes cinématographique mais aussi
le cas de paul lycéens français je
compte faire une fac d'histoire et par
la suite peut-être une école de
journalisme et du coup ça m'intéressait
bien tout ça ça fait bizarre de voir en
vrai tout ce qu'on voit à la télé
d'habitude et puis c'est une occasion
qu'on n'aura pas forcément plusieurs
fois dans sa vie quoi pour anne-sophie
en revanche ce n'est pas encore ça ça
t'intéresse justement de plus tard
l'avenir pourquoi pas être journée
destinée rédiger des critiques à
l'avenir j'ai déjà pensé pour autant je
suis jamais dit que je m'orienterais
dans cette voie
quelle serait ta première critique on va
dire bah j'avais jamais vu de film sur
le thème des prisons comme ça pas ainsi
mais sur le thème de la rééducation
après et c'est intéressant et ça parle
bien je trouve ça décrit l'ambiance de
corruption un peu du pays et deux essais
assez malsain comme ambiance et comme
atmosphère aussi nouvelle étape pour le
lycéens français et allemands rendez
vous ici au collège international de
cannes ils vont aller à la rencontre de
xavier leherpeur il est journaliste
cinéma mais aussi critique au programme
discussions et échanges sur les films a
vu ces derniers jours mais aussi la
rédaction d'une interview de simon
broillet réalisateur xavier est ce que
vous pouvez dans un premier temps nous
expliquer les objectifs de cette de
cette journée ici avec les lycéens on a
essayé déjà dans une première partie de
l'atelier de décompter leurs émotions
leur ressenti sur lesquels ils se sont
arrêtés les questions qu'ils se posent
les ambiguïtés du récit et qu'on va
transformer tout ça dans une deuxième
partie en entretien avec le réalisateur
à l'entretien qui j'espère répondre à
leurs interrogations
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que tu as retenu
justement de ce matin des conseils de
xavier sur sur la critique sur le cinéma
en général bah la critique c'est pas
forcément donner son avis et l'exprimer
et fins et donner son avis mais les
données d'une façon construite et que
pour
pour faire une interview faut aussi
écouter et réagir à ce que disent les
autres à ce que dit celui qu'on
intervient justement l'après midi même
les élèves pourront enfin faire part de
leurs interrogations au réalisateur
simon witts je suis à présent avec anne
tallineau vous êtes secrétaire général
de l'ofag l'office franco allemand pour
la jeunesse alors la principale mission
de l'oph hc promouvoir les échanges et
les rencontres interculturelles entre la
france et l'allemagne vous êtes ici à
cannes dans ce but mais avant de parler
de votre présence pour le 75e festival
de cannes est-ce que vous pouvez nous
rappeler rapidement en quelques mots
l'histoire de l'oph âge et son
importance dans les relations et
l'amitié franco allemande
mais l'histoire l'hommage est intimement
liée à l'amitié